I saw someone die late last night
Have you been taking your medication
You don't get it
She's here
She followed me here
You're not in your right state of mind
Look
Yesterday we just dropped the short film "You Monster" on the Corridor channel
Now this piece explores how audiences affect creators and we're gonna sit down with Anthony Padilla, who plays the lead character Ashton
Now he's a veteran of the Youtube game. He's had an audience for years
We're gonna see how the themes of this piece resonate with his personal life and experiences
What we shot this piece back in November and then uh, there's been a worldwide pandemic and a large
Uh movement against police brutality since then
Has it ever felt appropriate to release this. I mean even now it's like
Damn, the world is just very different than it was eight months ago when we shot it
Yeah, you know, but it's one of those things where I don't want to keep sitting on it
I just want to put it out there because you know the question this piece asks is how does an audience change things?
You know sometimes for the worse sometimes for the better, you know, you're somebody who's had an audience
You've had an audience for a long time. I mean you're you're a veteran of of the industry at this point
You took part this project. You know you brought your acting talents to the table
Obviously we're friends, we go back a ways, but was there anything that spoke to you personally in this?
Is there anything that like stood out as a message that you that made you interested?
Yeah, I mean I think the whole
Concept of an audience wanting you to document things
and people who, you know, get obsessed with these numbers and engagement
It becomes very easy as someone who does social media to start gravitating toward the things that get you the most
engagement, the most viewership because that translates to
Success in all the different ways. I feel like a lot of people get in their head
I'll use these cheap tactics whenever I can, because it'll allow me to do more things
It'll unlock more doors for me in the future
I don't think it's necessarily malicious
I don't think there's this intent to do things that are inherently evil, but I think some people get
Just blinded by
The opportunities that success can open up
Have you ever found yourself doing something or not doing something specifically because you have an audience
I think there was a time
You know when, when things started becoming more what some people call PC culture?
And there was a time where I made really edgy jokes because I thought they were funny because they were shocking
Um, and there was, I think there was a brief moment where I didn't understand
reasons for why some things weren't appropriate, but I feel like I was able to
Learn why it affected people and in turn kind of become more empathetic with why people, you know, found certain things
offensive or
Why people should or shouldn't say certain things.
So, I feel like over the years I've, I've started to
understand and learn more why things affect people in different ways
So, I don't find myself having to hold back at all because I actually my mentality
my view of
The things going on in the world has just changed so drastically since that time
When you can work that stuff into your core and just be who you are
Naturally, that's you know
That's the best state you can possibly be in, you know, with the role of the audience this video
Obviously, it casts a negative light on how people can influence. Uh
And encourage people to do things that they otherwise wouldn't do, but you know, it's not all negatives, you know
Do you have any examples of positives where you think, you know an audience putting attention onto something has has made things better
Yeah, I mean, I think, I think even right now with the Black Lives Matter movement with so much focus on police brutality
And systemic racism, and I think it's really had a positive effect because people have seen so much encouragement from their audience
And just the media in general to, to speak up about these things. So I think there has been some positivity
Yeah, there's also been negative too, but I think in many ways there has been a ton of positive
What, what responsibility do you think an audience has, uh, to the content they consume?
It's funny you ask that, the audience is in some ways directly responsible for what kind of content gets made
Because you're voting with your view, if you want more content like that to be made. If you're someone who hate watches things
You know, you're like, I hate this so much, but I love how much I hate it
I love talking with my friends about how much I hate it.
You're voting for more content like that to be made
It's half the person who creates the content and then it's half
The audience telling that creator that they want more of that to be made
And then with their view also giving them the money to fund doing more of that as well
It's a really good insight on it I have to agree with you
It's definitely, it's like voting with your dollar, except you're voting with your view
You know, people... people feel like there's a million people watching video
Why would your view impact it, but at the same time I see so many reminders of how small the world is
That one view does make a difference, that one comment you make does make a difference
It's small, but at the same time it's not small
The moment you get 5, 10, 20, 100 people saying the same thing
100 comments on a Youtube video, even if it's a super popular one, all saying the same thing, like at least for me, I noticed that creators take notice to that
Yeah, yeah
And I would say to people out there
Don't get discouraged by how big the numbers are, keep in mind that an individual is still very powerful
Absolutely
Every once in a while there's a single comment that gives me some insight into something, either that i'm going to do, or something that I have done that
Completely shifts my, my perception of the way that I would go about doing that and I think it's super important
Everyone should be speaking up more if they have something to say
I think that, you know, at least I think you can speak to and I can speak to, is you do get a chance
As a person with an audience to refine yourself for the better, to polish off those rough edges
And get a greater understanding of people across all different walks of life and how things work
And I think that's a responsibility as a creator, that you bring to the table when you have an audience
You know, that it's important that you grow with that audience to not only learn from the audience
But then take that learning from the audience and give it back to them, that they can learn as well
You know, it's all just one big circle of education
Yeah, absolutely
I say like, you know, look back at content that you used to make 10 or 15 years ago or even imagine that you
Are who you were 10 or 15 years ago and look at the content that you make now and you could just see how much
Growth there has been and i'm sure a huge part of that has been interacting with your audience and learning from them
And then in turn kind of shaping your view of the world at the same time
Yeah
So to tie this back to "You Monster"
When do you film and when do you help?
When does it become not okay, to continue having your phone out?
And when do you get involved?
If you were in a situation, let's say, you were witnessing a fight
When do you think it's okay to be recording it?
And when do you think a line gets crossed?
And you should either no longer be recording it, or you should step in, to do something about it
It's best to quickly assess the situation
"Am I safe?"
"Would it be safe for me to step in?"
And if the answer is, "Yes, It would be safe"
Then you should definitely go and help
Like in "You Monster", my character should have definitely helped
There was nothing that would have hurt me
In going up and like, helping that person or talking to them or trying to understand what was going on in their mind
But, you know, say it's an instance where there's some kind of violence going on or obviously police brutality, you know
I think if you can't directly contribute because it might be putting your life in danger in some way
It would probably be best to record that, so you could show people and talk about it and make it a bigger thing
With George Floyd in that unfortunate situation
They, they didn't feel safe stepping in
So, I think they did the best that they could do and that was document it
So that it could spark a discussion and in turn there's been an entire worldwide movement because of that
So I think those people did the best that they could do with the situation that they were in
Yeah I think it's great insight and, uh, good advice also
You know, I want to say thank you again, for getting involved in this project
For lending, you know, your... your talents on screen and taking the time to nail the character and help us make a piece
That's a little bit more than just a VFX action scene
Yeah, absolutely, I had a great time
I mean, as a director you gave a lot of freedom to, uh, improvise
It just, you pulled something, that feels so big together with such a small crew and small budget
And uh, i'm really, really happy with how it turned out
So, thank you for having me be part of that
You bet man
You know, thanks for taking a minute of your day here to talk to us
And uh, I look forward to getting that video out there and seeing what people think
Absolutely, man, thank you
And uh, you know, thanks to the whole production team, it was a really fun time
I'd love to hear your thoughts
I'd love to hear if you think audiences bear any responsibility in the content that is created for them
And if so, what kind of responsibility do they bear?
Have you ever personally been affected by having an audience?
You know, I know not everybody out here has, you know, say Youtube channels or Instagram followings
But even small followings
Has that shaped or changed the way you approach life?
Have you ever been recording a video and been thinking to yourself
"I maybe should put my phone away and get involved in some other way, than just filming it"
Let me know in the comments below
I'd love to hear your stories
I'd love to hear your thoughts
I'd love for you to go check out "You Monster"
It's a piece that we put a lot of work into
It's an idea I've had for a long time
And you should also go check out Anthony's channel
He does some awesome eye-opening sit-downs where he talks to really interesting people
So we'll have links for his stuff as well
All right
Happy watching